I think Ukraine is uh about to go on the
offensive I mean that's what's going to
happen uh once the spring thaw has
happened and what tanks are really
really useful for is punching through
defensive positions or front lines and
and they're highly maneuverable and they
take their Firepower with them so you
can either go through Russian units or
around them and so you're right we have
gone from you know originally anti-tank
missiles to air defense to artillery to
now we're asking for tanks and actually
what's happened is that's tracked the
stages of the war primarily at the
beginning Ukraine was on the defensive
but now they've retaken three key areas
back off the Russians and they're ready
to go onto the offensive so they need
the Weaponry to allow them to do that